all right we are now live for another
reading from my book reason fulfilled by
revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in france i see a
question here from ephron what is this
supposed to be what lecture is it well
it says it right there in the video
description
this book and we've been doing live
readings from this for quite some time
we are now deep in the third part of the
book and today
we are going to be looking at bruno
disolages the problem of christian
philosophy which was published in la vie
onse lexie well
volume 25 number three 1933 you see it
right here um and so
this is kind of an unusual piece
compared to the others most of the
others are
a bit more academically oriented this is
an academic lecture but a lecture to the
general public who had by this time
become quite interested in this topic
and you know what was going on with it
so you'll see that as soon as i start
reading it
so with no further ado i'll start and
then afterwards i'll take questions
comments and you know we can go for
about an hour uh if if we need to
so
lords ladies and gentlemen once a year
the universities open wide their doors
to the public and the public enters
there with a sympathetic curiosity in
the hope of gaining a glimpse of the
mysterious occupations of the
university's inhabitants
we are in one of those days and the
delicate task falls upon me of forcing
you to make an excursion into our domain
it is vast and includes quite varied
regions which one should i choose for
our excursion this year
although our studies travel ceaselessly
along the immutable substance of things
they nevertheless do not neglect to
submit just a little to the law of
contemporane contemporaneity
also ladies assuming that our austere
embrace is not completely set to flight
your preoccupations with fashion i
thought that would be fitting to choose
the trail we traversed from among the
problems that have been
if i dare say so in fashion among us the
last years
the ascent i propose to you
is not one of the easiest it belongs to
that zone of lofty mountains of
philosophical thought whose borders
neighbor those even more mysterious of
theology still i believe that i can
assure you that you do not risk any
mortal accident or even more a
temptation to nap and that in any case
in a half hour i will have brought you
to the lodge
the recent debate about christian
philosophy since that is what we will
talk about
has not been a specifically
ecclesiastical debate we did not see it
at the start in dominican and jesuit
circles but rather it was at the
sorbonne and the college de france that
opened fire an article by mr brejiere
and the review de mere physique editor
morale had laid out the problem of a
christian philosophy's existence and
resolved it with a rattle rather brutal
negation mr jill song took up the
challenge
the paris society di philosophy devoted
to it one of its sessions and when the
philosopher of ikes that is blondel had
raised the problem for the marcel
society philosophy contributions flowed
in from everywhere from toulouse in
particular
and mr devil vay's letter to mr blondel
is certainly not one of the least
interesting pieces contributed to this
debate
philosophers opponents and partisans of
our beliefs thus kept running across
each other in this discussion one
quickly admitted to be an intellectual
crossroads
what was it all about
the landscape is complex with multiple
planes and points of view or
sufficiently numerous interesting
perspectives reveal themselves
would you like that we step into the
historians belvedere first of all since
they are the ones who started it it is a
question
of knowing what christianity's influence
on the movement of philosophical thought
has been
these questions of influence are always
tricky ones how can we exactly determine
what in modern philosophy derived from a
christian source when a river and its
tributary have mixed their water it is
quite difficult to discern what came
from the tributary
still if one can fortunately go back to
their meeting place each one's
contribution is more easily perceptible
it reminds me of having often in my
childhood from the height of the
majestic arches of the bridge of tarn
situated some meters beyond its joining
with the agut contemplated the line of
demarcation of its brick red waters and
the green waters constituting its
tributaries contribution this line
becomes more and more indecisive up to
the point where the complete fusion of
the two currents causes it to disappear
but at the beginning
it is conspicuously precise
going back to the conflicts of greek
philosophy's current with christian
thought mr joson was able to show by the
historian's precise method
the originality of the christian
contribution to western thought
on points of major importance like the
idea of creation of which we barely find
a trace in philosophical discussions
before the eruption of the christian
waters
at a meeting of the society thomist
convened in juvensie to elucidate this
same problem another historian the
reverend father festuzier
highlighted as particularly significant
this fact already raised by mr jill sol
that one of the notion's most dear to
modern thought the notion of the person
was completely effaced not to mention
absent in ancient thought and in a
singularly striking point that this was
a definite acquisition due to christian
influence
the fact of this christian influence on
the development of philosophical ideas
has quickly appeared i believe
sufficiently established for the
majority of philosophers who have taken
sides in the debate so that taking up
this very influence as a basis for
discussion they have raised the question
of its nature
and its legitimacy
in actuality if we restricted ourselves
to simply noting christianity's
influence on philosophy there would be
nothing there that would raise a
particularly interesting problem for the
reflection of philosophers for the
history of systems teaches us that each
new system exercises and influence on
the others even if this is only by
reaction it would not be difficult to
show that contemporary tomism itself at
least that which is valuable
would not be exactly what it is if kant
had not existed since christianity is a
doctrine at the same time as a life it
is entirely natural that its influence
would have made itself felt on the
movement of ideas and that the influence
would be discernible to the historian
historians microscope
but
what is most instructive is knowing the
nature of this influence does it appear
and straight away even to the
historian's gaze as something with its
own peculiar nature sui generous that is
the question i allowed myself during the
session of discussions i alluded to
earlier to put to mr joseon here's a
translator's note the question dislodges
runs alludes to runs in the eyes of the
historian which you are and according to
historical methods is christianity's
influence on philosophical movement
christianity's new contribution
similar to the influence of another
great philosopher or of a philosophical
school introducing new ideas
or does this influence possess something
specific something that does not
resemble any other influence
all right back to the text
the eminent professor from the college
de france did want to recognize that the
question was in fact a central one but
when
one raises a question
with a certain degree of precision
most often it is because one already has
some idea about the response and since
mr gilson was not here today you allow
me to respond in his place
for anyone
who attempts to analyze closely
christianity's influence on philosophy
there is no doubt that this influence
does not exercise itself in the way that
the influence of in philosophical
systems does
those appear as the result of an inquiry
of reason and barely separate themselves
from the stages through which that
inquiry is passed to arrive at this
result they present themselves as
rational conclusions grounded on
rational proofs
things go differently for christian
doctrine when it makes its entrance into
the history of philosophy it presents
itself as a completely finished datum
the object of a revelation one must
believe without direct proof on the
authority of god this is precisely the
aspect that it already struck christ's
first audiences he did not speak we read
in the gospels like the scribes and the
pharisees but as one having authority
christian dogma
presents itself to the believing
philosopher not only as containing some
new philosophical values that up to this
point had no circulation in the
marketplace of ideas but also as data
discovered by a new procedure completely
different from philosophical procedure
it has got himself in a way who has made
the data be offered to them in the
marketplace of ideas
so for the believing philosopher these
philosophical data of dogma are not only
new ideas to examine they are
from the start and without philosophical
proofs truths
they therefore constitute for him
directives that one accepts but then
and here is the problem
if the philosophy he will elaborate
under these directives can obviously in
this sense be denominated christian
can we still truly call it philosophy
at the stage of the question where we
actually stand
and this is of central importance in
order to grasp the very meaning of the
debate what is contested is not the
possibility of such a doctrine under
christian influence being born and
baptized christian
it is whether it has the right once born
to be named philosophy
a christian theology being possible
under these conditions that's fine a
christian
but a philosophy that is a purely
rational doctrine elaborated by reason
and accepting into its framework nothing
that would be that would not be
demonstrable by reason
doesn't this influence on philosophy
that we claim for christianity corrupt
philosophy in its very essence
now believing philosophers are
intransigent as their colleagues about
the necessity for a philosophy properly
called to appeal only to exclusively
rational arguments i still hear father
mondonet making his points and with such
vamments on this matter mr mariten has
elucidated this problem very well and
characterized the situation in which
philosophy taking up its abode or born
in the brain of a believer is found by
saying it does not change its nature but
its state what does that mean
that reason continues to open up
philosophical work by itself but reason
finds itself in new conditions of
exercise its normal mechanism has not
changed at all its play is simply
rendered easier and more sure the work
produced remains entirely and
exclusively rational
if that is true
then what does the difference and what
does the difference consist
it is similar enough to the difference
between making the ascension of the mesh
or the grepon with a guide or without a
guide
but if you you will say if the guide
pulls on the rope every once in a while
they'll lift you up to the summit will
you claim that you climb there under
your own powers if your reasonings hang
from revelation at one place or another
will you claim you're still doing
philosophy
that is exactly the point the guide
should not pull up on the rope there are
in fact two ways of making a climb with
a guide
one in which the guide lifts you and
another in which he simply indicates to
you the path and you climb up by your
own powers
when the guide pulls on the rope i mean
when your demonstrations are hanging
from revelation you're doing theology
but in christian philosophy the
demonstrations are not hanging from
revelation in any way the guy does not
pull up on the rope
throwing yourself then over to the other
extreme will you say well in that case
it does not do anything there is no
influence on your movement well
do you believe that it would be nothing
to indicate the path or even simply
where the true peak is i mean the way of
demonstration or even simply the truth
that would have to be demonstrated it's
quite clear you have not made many a
sense philosophical ones that is and
that you believe candidly that a
philosopher never makes a mistake about
the path
but there are others
who claim to the contrary that simply
pointing out the path rigs the game let
us understand this
if it is a matter of competition and of
merit it is very true that in the march
to truth the other philosophers are
handicapped in comparison to the
christian philosopher that we not only
recognize we proclaim it but if it is a
matter of rational
correctness of demonstrations we deny
that this rigs their game as soon as it
is well understood that the christian
philosopher will not admit a revealed
truth to take a place in his philosophy
unless he has succeeded and he does not
always succeed
in giving a correct rational
demonstration as a preliminary
will you say that the mathematician who
resolves by arithmetic a problem whose
solution he knew in advance thanks to
algebra would no longer do arithmetic
yet it often makes things easier to know
the result in advance
the christian philosopher does not seek
whether god exists since insofar as
christian he knows it but he seeks to
prove by reason that god exists
this simplifies his labor
since he knows where it will be useful
to look
but
this does not give him a dispensation
dispensation from committing himself to
the task and if it happens he too easily
contests himself with a demonstration
that is not apodictic his brother in
argument might just end up being more
severe with him than an opponent did not
saint thomas deny any value to saint
anselm's proof perhaps you will say
considering things subjectively the
believing philosopher has the temptation
of setting aside his demonstrations in
favor of dogma
doesn't the unbeliever have the
temptation to do exactly the inverse one
should not give into temptations
this is also part of the dogma to be
demonstrated it is necessary to be of an
intransigent sincerity is this not the
first lesson of the gospel and of
revelation
in our climb to the domain of christian
philosophy ladies and gentlemen i have
made you come along this far with some
personal variations for which i am
responsible on two itineraries which i
will call for commodities sake the
jillsone trail and the marathon trail
it remains for me to make you travel
along another one the blown del trail
none of the three lead to the same peak
for our mountain has three peaks but it
seems to me that the view that one has
from each of them
marvelously completes the view that one
has from the others and that all three
allow one to make for oneself a
sufficiently complex and exact idea of
this complex reality
i will even go so far as to express the
opinion
that the ideal course is to combine all
three trails into a single one that
allows us to successfully successively
visit the three summits in a single day
moving from one to the other that is why
i make you take this course traversing
it we have succeeded if you remember in
moving from mr gilson's point of view
which is historical to mr mara ten's
point of view which is philosophical
by the help of a question put to mr jill
so a second question which we would put
to mr mariten if he were here will allow
us to move to mr blondel's point of view
which is also a philosophical point of
view
philosophy has undergone the influence
of christianity that is what mr joseon
proves
why does this influence not resemble
that of others because it is the direct
influence of a revealed truth that does
not modify the nature but only the
conditions of philosophical labor mr
mara 10 has made us answer
but what good is this divine revelation
of truths when making them enter into
christian philosophy one must discover a
rational proof of it if airplanes were
only used to arrive at mountaintops men
would not have had the idea to invent
them why would god have amused himself
by revealing to us truths that we are
capable of finding
ourselves
so that we would find them more easily
if revelation had only that end
we are right to find the means
disproportionate to the end he had only
to strengthen our reason and it would
have dispensed with his extraordinary
guide revelation
we can truly understand a revealed truth
taught to humanity from authority only
if we understand it to be a truth
inaccessible to reasons path forging
but how could a truth be from its very
nature inaccessible to reason which is
the instrument of knowledge proportion
to nature if not in the case where it
would bear on a reality transcendent to
nature a supernatural one revelation
cannot justify itself unless it is at
the start
revelation of something that overflows
the natural order
only that which is outside of nature
outside of the domain on which reason
nature's dear daughter exercises a
royalty of birth rightly escapes reason
but in fact this is just the way that
christian revelation presents itself it
does not contribute to us only truths
that reason is not though it could have
discovered it contributes to us truths
that reason could not discover
for they are from a plane to which
reason does not have the ability to
climb it is primordially revelation of
the supernatural and if by surplus it
brings along with the following of
natural truths it is in reason's power
to verify this is because the
supernatural order harmonizes well only
with a correctly defined natural order
and because to promote this boxing up of
the supernatural inside nature it
contributes along with it what is needed
for rectifying nature and directing
reason
the airplane is made for something quite
other than helping mountain climbers its
own domain and its reason for being are
well beyond the summits it is only by
surplus that flying alongside of
particularly high mountains like the
himalayas it can supply mountain
climbing expeditions supplementary
facilities for discovering the true path
but if this aspirate affirmation of the
supernatural by christian revelation
itself explains that it raises in its
turn of philosophical difficulty that is
a new aspect of the problem of christian
philosophy
it is not only the legitimacy of
revelation and the the nature of its
indirect influence on the philosophical
movement that is under discussion it is
the legitimacy of the very object of
that revelation
for the philosopher the question raised
is that of the very idea of the
supernatural
is the supernatural conceivable possible
compatible truly that is the major
problem on which christianity obliges
philosophy to take aside
it is not at all a question let us
understand this well of making
philosophy resolve the question of the
factual existence of the supernatural
for this by its very definition
not being of the order of the necessary
but of the order of the contingent
depends by hypothesis solely on the
divine liberality and escapes from the
competence of the philosophical tribunal
the question is is there a place in a
rational conception of the world for the
supernatural and not this place is it
occupied and by what and how
many of you
doubtless remember those geography maps
from the old atlases from the times when
we went to school where they were still
at the center of africa for example big
areas without names and all labeled
terra incognita unknown lands
does there exist on the philosophical
map of the universe a place for an
unknown land more precisely unknowable
even by our customary means a
predestined
empty space that only the existence of a
supernatural order and its revelation
could come to fill
mr blondel's entire philosophical work
going on now a half century has spared
no effort to force even unbelieving
philosophers to admit that they had to
put on their map an unknown land that
nature was not an irredeemably closed
reality
but rather that it remained opened
toward infinity and that in this sense
in the end all true philosophy the true
philosophy should be called christian
i will dare to say that this second
aspect of the problem of christian
philosophy is postulated by the first
and without paradox if not without
mischief that mr blondel justifies mr
mara 10 for mr maritan's position on
christian philosophy would be untenable
if mr blondel's position was not true
how indeed would revelation be able to
aid reasons exercise if reason was from
its very nature powerless to arrive at
the end point of the mystery of things
and how would a reason made to the
measure of nature necessarily have a
need in order to know the real for a
super added divine light if there was
not something in the real that exceeded
nature and with which nature would still
however harmonize only the orientation
of nature towards the supernatural can
explain in its ground how the revelation
of the supernatural ameliorates the
normal play of reason how a reason
illuminated by faith functions better
than a reason that does not benefit at
all from that light
ever since christianity's appearance
philosophy can no longer ignore the
problem to one who looks at matters only
superficially it could seem that the
problem of christianity's influence on
philosophy touches only believers that
is not the case
faced with this doctrinal claim of
christianity accepted by so many of
their colleagues unbelieving
philosophers are insofar as philosophers
obliged to take a side and to take a
side to deny the legitimacy of the idea
of the supernatural just as much as to
accept it one must study
and give some reasons
that is why historical examination of
christian philosophy's existence raises
the problem of its legitimacy for
unbelievers themselves it is not because
christianity would present itself like
the other doctrines rather to the
contrary it's exactly because it does
not present itself like the other
doctrines but as a revealed doctrine
that it raises for the philosopher on
the philosophical plane a problem of a
specifically philosophical order that is
at the heart of all the discussions
about christian philosophy that are the
very acceptability of the idea of the
supernatural
and that is why
when the problem is raised in a way
rigorously faithful to philosophical
method
the philosopher at least he who is not
afraid of any problem and who does not
have any prejudice against any solution
cannot refuse examining it
to this supreme question of the
legitimacy of the supernatural
does philosophy when interrogated answer
yes or no if it answered no and truly
justified its negation then yes under no
aspect could a philosophy be called
christian even in the restricted sense
that we have just the limited
but if it affirms this legitimacy and if
it proves it if it shows by a
scrupulously exhaustive analysis of the
real that nature remains open to the
infinite that there is even in nature a
call of mysterious origin towards the
supernatural
if it is pascal who is right then by the
fact alone that it will itself mark its
own limits and admit its own
insufficiency philosophy to court the
true philosophy will be able to
pronounce itself naturally christian
philosophy in the sense that tertullian
said the human soul and quest of the
infinite was naturally christian
having made it thus far
the recent debate on christian
philosophy brings us by another root to
the problem philosophical and
theological at the same time of
imminence it raises once again the
eternal problem of the nate of the the
relations between nature and the
supernatural
reassure yourself ladies and gentlemen
one does not usually make two such
climbs in a single day and your guide
for the moment would fear to wear out
his tourists and their so amiable
attention we will be content for today
with having made the climb to a summit
from which ample perspectives open up
onto other summits to climb and with
having noted that what separates from a
philosophical point of view believers
and unbelievers is the idea that they
make for themselves of the way in which
the world is closed for the unbeliever
the circle of thought closes up again on
itself nature is closed without windows
opening to a transcendent
for us others christians from the summit
from which we embrace the world we look
beyond the stars our thought climbs
towards the infinite mystery our heart
feels vibrate in itself an uncoercible
need for the eternal and it seems to us
to see the universe as a whole around us
in us and by us orient itself towards
god
and to the mountain climber who has
served as our symbol the highest
mountains seem to raise themselves
towards the creator and he names the
most beautiful summits in the mesh the
finger of god
so that is bruno de salaja's
presentation
[Music]
in
la vie antelectuel the problem of
christian philosophy a more public
address than
those that we find in the academic
journals and the learned philosophy
societies i very much like this piece
one of the things that i like the most
about it is it's hard to come up with
good metaphors and analogies although
as we know those are so often
very important in conveying ideas and in
bringing people you know
from one point of view to another this
notion of making three climbs up a
mountain chain we could say
a jolson itinerary a maraten itinerary a
blown dell itinerary and that they're
not all going to exactly the same peak
but rather three peaks
that allow a kind of composite vision to
be formed that's a cool metaphor you
know desolage was was a pretty pretty
smart guy all right mark says uh
uh
hey everyone as usual hope you're all
well yeah i hope everybody's doing well
as well
um danny to what degree to what extent
do you think blondel was influenced by
pascal blondel says that he's very
influenced by pascal
and that's from early on if you read his
carnet on team you know he'll talk about
pascal's orders and the importance of
the order of charity
you know one of the things that pascal
brings to the table is this this this
central insight that human beings
what what is you know there in our human
nature is greatness and misery and we
better pay attention to both of them we
better pay attention to our strengths
and our weaknesses we better pay
attention to our self-sufficiency and
where we're lacking
and i guess i mean what what dislodge is
saying
is that this notion that blondel
develops in his own contributions and in
the ones that are untranslated like his
uh the problem of the philosophy
catholique an entire book and a few
other ones that that didn't get
translated like of philosophy in 1936
this idea of their
philosophy when it's being sufficiently
attentive being sufficiently honest not
being able to close itself up in a
conceptual system that says oh i've got
everything handled but rather finding
gaps
holes lacunae he's got a whole bunch of
metaphors for this you know a
big vocabulary
i think you can say that that is coming
from pascal
blondel
very influenced by pascal also very
influenced by leibniz also influenced by
quite a few other people as well but
pascal is somebody who londell returns
to over and over again
as a matter of fact even in some other i
believe at this point in time
untranslated works
he defends pascal from
the um
charge of jansenism right
danny has another question have you read
the most recent translation of blondel's
work by olive oblash on philosophical
exigencies of christian religion i've
not only read it uh in the original in
french when i was doing my dissertation
i reviewed for
the press
oliver blanchett's
piece and provided them with a part of
the go-ahead for um
publishing it uh blanchett is is a
brilliant guy i've actually met him at
the metaphysics colloquium in um
uh saint anselm's college before
and i had a correspondence going on with
him i think i've mentioned this in
previous ones you know he
there's a couple things that he's done
that are really great one is he
re-translated accion 1893 and back when
i was a graduate student and i was
writing my dissertation on blondel
i was in a correspondence with him and i
said why did you re-translate it and
um
blanchette wrote me back and he said
have you read the have you read the
earlier translation the somerville
translation i said no i mean i just read
it in french he said go ahead and take a
look at it and then go ahead and take a
look at my translation
and then look at the french and i did
that and i was like oh
i see what you mean he's like yeah i've
been teaching this text and the english
translation
was had so many things where i had to
take exception that i was like i better
just translate this myself you know and
that's that's what he did
um
he also has an amazing uh like
thousand page
philosophical biography of blondel that
i i also reviewed back when it came out
i think it was 2010
and one of the things that i put into
the review is you know i'm i'm a
researcher on blondel and there was
stuff in this
that i didn't know about so blanchette
is really the guy
on blondel i mean not the only person
obviously but he's pretty amazing
um fear and trembling
thanks for these and specifically
direction on tackling blondel currently
trying to pick him up hope to see more
on him in the future well
he's you know he's an undeservedly
neglected figure he's um he's difficult
to work on
in part because his writing style is
rather difficult and not all that much
has been translated so his great
metaphysical trilogy
uh which is actually five volumes of le
ponce
so thought la tresep being and
beings and a new version of laxion which
is actually two volumes that came out in
the 30s has not been translated as danny
was pointing out philosophical demands
or exigencies of christian religion has
been that's great
there's a ton of blondel stuff that has
just not been translated and you know
it's it's not all that readily available
even in its french stuff you sometimes
have to go to libraries to to find it
so
uh
yeah
danny asks if i'm catholic yeah i was i
was raised catholic left the church came
back
um i can't claim to be a particularly
good or devout catholic i think that you
know it's not particularly relevant to
doing good work
um
and you know catholic can mean a lot of
different things to look at you know
trad catholics or ultra liberal
catholics and they're not really
catholic in any real sense of the term
you can say that i work within the
catholic intellectual tradition but that
means to work for somebody like blondel
in contact with
everything else
so
um
mark what you read earlier about
revelation is revelation and
epistemological possibility to anyone
is revelation necessary for a
relationship
with christ
okay so two good questions um
and you know it's interesting because
we can say
it's tempting to say that like in our
time
revelation
of the supernatural is indeed a
possibility for everyone
because
we're in this vast interconnected world
in a very different way than they were
you know in the 1930s when
uh
places were sort of closing off on
themselves and but
there's two things that get in the way
there
actually three
one is not everybody has access you
could say
and even if they do they
they might have gotten wrong-headed
ideas that stand in the way like if you
know if you're brought up
thinking there's nothing to religion
it's all [ __ ] you know we you know
we're in a world that's secularizing
um it's
tough if you're the ordinary kind of
person to
tap into anything that would be a
revelation and and then there's also the
difficulties involved in revelation you
know you've got
people
teaching and preaching all sorts of
stuff that's kind of extraneous
and often gets in the way as well so
that's that's one significant problem
there there's another problem it's
interesting we talk about pascal because
this is the weakness of pascal's wager
right pascal's wager is this pragmatic
argument for the existence of god
and it says well you're better off
believing than not believing because if
you get it if you get it right that's
great if you get it wrong you're really
screwed if you if god doesn't exist then
you're
you know just missing out on a few
pleasures but you still live a decent
life and stuff like that
well pascal's wager the the really
problematic aspect of it is well which
god which religion
and
if we say
that we should be open to the
supernatural and
philosophy has to do that
okay maybe it has to do that in relation
to christianity but
why doesn't it why doesn't it have to do
that in relation to at least some
schools of buddhism
or hinduism
or islam
or and we can go down the line right
this is a really significant issue
to think about
how do we know that we're on track with
the right one and so we probably look
for you know religions that are actually
in in
contact with and in discourse with
other faiths which we can find i mean
they do exist right
um so that's that's an interesting
problem now is revelation necessary for
a relationship with christ
i don't know myself all i can tell you
is what what people
say about this i think that that a lot
of this is something that was really
contested within
um within christianity
um you know there are other virtuous
pagans that are recognized right and and
some some would say well there aren't
any virtuous pagans unless you've had
the gospel preached to you and accepted
jesus in your heart uh you're screwed
right
uh not all christians think that way you
know it's it's more like well you got a
better chance
if you've got these these texts it's
sort of and there's a similar problem by
the way for buddhism why in maya hana
buddhism are there like buddhas in all
these different places and times why for
a certain kind you know hindu uh things
why does vishnu take on multiple avatars
so that people aren't screwed they have
a they have a chance to encounter
revelation right
um
all right
danny how does father joseph marshall
fit into these debates at all well we
actually covered him
uh just a few sessions back in mr in in
blondel's the problem of catholic
philosophy which was his presentation to
the society detude uh philosophique we
had letters
and
here we go
comments of mr
joseph marichal
jesus right
uh he he took part in the debates
a fairly minor part he he also had an
interesting article
that figures in there let me look at the
bibliography that that compares blondel
uh
to
husserl if i remember right
and i'm blanking on the
year in which that was published i want
to say it's fairly early
in the debates or perhaps even right
before
uh
things kick off
marshall here we go yeah uh this is in
1930
phenomena phenomenology pure or
philosophy
published in philosophy parents
for gangnam height and gegenvard edited
by fritz joachim von richten
[Music]
later reprinted
along with correspondence avec maurice
blondel that is you know of course the
correspondence with blondel in melange
joseph mareshall
volume one published in
1950 by desklay
so he he figures in he's he's not a
major player you could say but he's he's
one of them you know 50 or so bit
players in the debates these debates
were pretty broad and involved a lot of
people
godo have you ever been interested in
gnosticism
uh didn't know you're a catholic i
always thought you were agnostic and
intuitive atheist i mean there's there's
where it goes i mean
if i'm presenting things properly it
shouldn't matter whether i'm catholic or
not right
and you know when i taught at indiana
state prison i actually had to keep my
my catholic identity
secret and i had to do so for several
reasons one was because if if it was
known that i was catholic then i would
have all the crazy um protestants and
and not all protestants are crazy as a
matter of fact most of them aren't but i
would have them you know like the
seventh day you know uh adventists and
all that were following uh helen or
ellen white where she says you know
crazy totally off-base things about
about uh church history i'd have them
like really biased against me
and i'd also have all the catholics
trying to get over on me because they'd
think well we've got that in common you
know and when you're doing you know this
sort of sort of work you you need to
put aside some of your
your um
commitments you could say so you can see
what people are actually saying that's
the philosophical approach to things
um
i don't know that like you know a lot of
agnostics and and atheists manage to
keep their
their agnosticism or atheism from
driving their own agendas too
they are often just as faith-driven as
anybody else
um interest in gnosticism yeah i've been
interested in gnosticism and i've taught
about it you know i used to teach a
class called jesus in the gospel
traditions pretty frequently when i was
teaching at indiana state prison and we
covered the canonical and non-canonical
gospels
and um
you know uh
we would talk about say the gospel of
thomas and we talk about gnostic
literature there's also by the way a
really great book that i would bring in
for them uh hans jonas uh the the
gnostic religion we would use some
chapters from that
um and you know i'm a big fan of philip
k dick who also is influenced by
gnosticism as well so yeah i get i get
quite a bit of that one of the things
you got to say about gnosticism is the
one thing agnosticated more than an
orthodox was another gnostic it's not as
if there's like a gnostic bible there's
there's actually a book out there that
calls itself that but it's complete
[ __ ] there's they didn't have a
single
uh
set of books that they all agreed upon
it was like this big messy thing and the
gnostics were not just um running into
problems from the orthodox christians
they also got criticized by the pagans
like um platinus right so neoplatonus
didn't like gnostics all that much
um
mark to follow up on my question my
experience with agape is that it's
something that comes from the outside
for lack of clear expression i wouldn't
be capable of this kind of love alone so
it seems like that experience must be
the result of revelation not of my own
reasoning or motivation even if i don't
necessarily consider it in a christian
terms of the moment yeah i wouldn't call
it a revelation revelation is like
something is being revealed and usually
a text or a person right i would say
it's more of an experience that
um
clearly surpasses one's own
[Music]
resources that you have already
and um
you know i i tend to think that
christians
are a little bit too
um
schematic and and
c.s lewis and anders negron are are
really at at fault for this and saying
you got agape there's totally
self-giving love and then you've got
philia and you know uh friendship and
then you've got eros sexual desire
desire libido and then you've got storge
or philostorgia which is like affection
i kind of think that all these open up
doors to that you know and and when
you're translating those things into
latin you gotta and you get run into
something like amor well which which one
are we talking about right so yeah
um
danny have you read a.g certian's book
on the intellectual life i actually
recommended it last session because it
was on sartiage i have certian's book
the intellectual life on my my bed stand
and i read through it every once in a
while i've been reading it since i was
in graduate school so yeah
uh danny have you read any of noel's
work on epistemology no the only noel
thing that i've ever read is the piece
in here
which is actually
the very last one
that we're going to be reading
there we go leon noel's the notion of
christian
philosophy
so i translated that i i haven't really
read other noel stuff and he was kind of
a bit player but i thought it was good
to have him in
this um this volume right and if i could
have included more translations in the
volume if catholic university of america
press
hadn't been you know more concerned with
making money and you know how long a
book could be i would have included more
but i didn't
um
go to i've been trying to get into kyoto
philosophy and came across this book
called religion and nothingness by
nishitani maybe you can make a video on
it i never want video suggestions quite
frankly i've got so much going on
already
uh if you want videos of a particular
thing then you should think about
commissioning them because otherwise you
know i've already got so much stuff on
my docket
and i am actually for the very first
time incorporating into my
existentialism class
some kyoto school stuff as a matter of
fact by nishitani um but
whether i'm going to shoot videos on it
we'll we'll see you know
um
stanislaw very cool i hadn't heard of
blondel before but i just found a text
of his so i'm going to check it out
right away i hope it's uh oxford 1993
because that's probably where you want
to start with blondel
um he does also have the letter on
apologetics and history of dogma
and also translated is
the idealist illusion in other essays
there is some other stuff that's been
translated in recent years as well i
want to say some of the correspondence
about
things in the
1910s and 20s have been translated but
not too much else but oxy 1983 is i
think where you really really want to
start um
oh mark says i i'm remaking my way
through pullman's dark materials
looking forward to what you have to say
about it next weekend
yeah so for those who don't know
we and this this also goes to the so
certain degree of the gnosticism
question
um i do this monthly thing called worlds
of speculative fiction in which i
release a video i do a video premiere
um talking about you know narrative
worlds philosophical themes in an
author's work so we did anathem uh by
neal stevenson
last uh
last month and we're doing philip
pullman's trilogy you know his dark
materials
this uh not this saturday but next
saturday
and then we have the two parable works
by octavia butler coming up in march
reading the first one right now and
really enjoying it by the way but no
surprise since octavia butler is well
worth reading so yeah we're going to be
talking about um there's so much there
to talk about with his dark materials
uh i was trying to also there's a bit of
a side note i was trying to also watch
the uh
the series
uh
but hbo
max has been crapping out on us just as
my wife and i were really really getting
into it i think we got to episode four
in the series and you know i've read the
books i'm like oh that's cool the way
they're doing this and and it's new to
my wife and now hbo max is uh
is
not working well with our amazon tv so
they don't they don't play nice together
maybe we'll get to see it maybe we won't
i guess there was a
film
of it that was
quite bad in in relation to the books
that basically took philip pullman's
very leery about traditional
christianity point of view and turned it
into christian propaganda which is
sometimes what happens to you right
so mark is providing the link there
the reason i owe
events calendar that tells you when
these things are coming up including
these these events right
all right so we got about 10 minutes
left a lot of good questions this time
any other questions or comments you want
me to
um
work on
so
danny says do you think someone will
eventually translate blondel's
metaphysical trilogy into english
one would hope but
you hope in part because you can't say
with probability that it's going to
happen
there was um there was a guy
back when i was still working at
fayetteville state university
so you know i was there from 2008 to
2011
who had wanted to start doing that who
wanted to put together a blondel
translation project
and i i was also asked to review his
book for catholic university of america
press
and panned it
because it wasn't well researched and i
think after that i became persona non
grata to him
i haven't seen anybody working on it
somebody asked me about that just the
other day why don't you translate these
and the answer is you're talking about
like
you know maybe 1800 pages of
french
literature
who's gonna who's gonna pay for that i
mean that's a lot of work a lot of time
then you've got to get it published
you know and the hoops that you have to
jump through with academic presses i
mean i could tell you a lot of stories
about what it took to actually get this
work published which almost didn't
happen at a couple different points and
you'd be like why would anybody put up
with that [ __ ]
the answer is because we're brainwashed
in academia to think that this is normal
you know
um
so i don't know i mean i have a
rough translation i did years and years
back of a short blonde l piece that i
think is really relevant in our time
his presentation to the cement social
called patri et humanite so homeland and
humanity and i would like to get that
re-worked because the last time i took a
look at it was over 10 years ago
rework that maybe publish it
[Music]
and uh that would that involves getting
permission from the blondel archives and
you know it's it's kind of a kind of a
mess to do those those sorts of things
um
but i'd like to do that and then maybe
do
if i was going to translate another
blondel work there's there's really two
shorter ones le problem de le
philosophica talique right that i
mentioned
um and then he also had a work on
mysticism uh that he he published in the
the um
uh
30s as well
i always see the mystic part of the
abrahamic religions like gnosticism
kabbalah sufism as more dynamic and
speculative aspects of religion
that's totally false i mean that people
enter into that first of all a lot of
that isn't mystical at all a lot of that
is just you know hermetic or it's you
know um sort of only there for the
initiates that doesn't make it actually
mystical i mean what makes something
properly mystical would be say that it
can't be put into words you know and
sufism spends a lot of time talking
about what you can't put into words
the kabbalah i can't really say that
much about christian gnosticism i can
say a lot of that's just you know
wild kooky crazy stuff and like i said
before a lot of them are more opposed to
other gnostics than they are even to the
orthodox so there's no sense of
romanticizing that you know
if you can actually take
orthodox literature and find what's
valuable in that
that's a greater feat than you know
entering into some basically ancient
conspiracy theory that says that the
orthodox have got it all wrong and we
the cool people have figured it out i'm
not saying that about sufism by the way
i am saying that about about gnosticism
and i can't say that about the kabbalah
because i i basically avoid anybody who
talks to me about it because i don't i
don't find it very interesting
i am not an i am not somebody interested
in
these sorts of um things for their own
sake um i think that if you can actually
you know read anselm and make sense out
of his his stuff uh somebody who's often
accused of being a rationalist
uh you actually have
done something quite quite amazing so
yeah
i'm not very i'm not a very congenial
person for that
any other questions comments that you
want me to engage in
all right well
we'll see if anybody writes anything
i'll remind you all that we're reading
from uh this book reason fulfilled by
revelation the 1930s christianity uh
christian philosophy debates in france
and coming up
next is going to be a long one that i
might need to split into
two parts because it's about 15 pages
i mean i might be able to read that in
40 minutes or so
you know we'll see but it's by fernan
von steinbergen
who's kind of a young guy sort of like
brahir was at the time
uh the society told me second day of
studies in the notion of christian
philosophy
published in the review neo scholastic
de philosophy
then um
responded to by blondel also in the
review neo-scholastic philosophy and
we're getting close to the end
of these these readings so
yeah um
godot ass any new sci-fi author you came
across um
well you know i'm just the ones that i'm
reading for for uh worlds of speculative
fiction because i'm so busy i don't
really have time for reading anything
that's not already like scheduled
um what do i think about the new dune
film i thought it was good i i you know
um i thought it was weird that a lot of
people
uh
you know focused in on
um
a sexual relationship between uh you
know paul and and his mother jessica
just because they took their clothes off
in front of each other you know um i
think there's a lot of like projection
going on there i thought you know the
visuals were pretty amazing i i liked it
i'm looking forward to the next
installation
um
it's uh certainly closer to the text
than
than uh
other adaptations have been
um and i'm actually thinking that that i
might
so i'll lay something out for you you
know i did the worlds of specula
internet world inspect the speculative
fiction studies videos right
and i did um a couple on philip jose
farmers the lovers which were over this
summer and then this fall i taught a
class on ursula k le guin's six earthsea
books in her two earlier earthsea
stories
and i produced videos from my students
that i finished releasing the last of
yesterday finally
and i pitched to my chair
that in the fall
i would teach another
speculative fiction class
this time focused on philip k dick and
it would include android's dream of
electric sheep three stigmata of palmer
eldritch
ubik
um
[Music]
blanking on the other one uh
they're all they're all in that four
novels from the 60s
oh man in the high castle and then uh
some some stories to go along with it as
well
and so if that that happens then i've
got to shoot a whole bunch of
speculative fiction studies
videos on um on those dick stories right
but
i considered about
shooting some stuff since dune is so
timely and people seem to be quite
interested in it some speculative
fiction studies
um stories on dune but then that means
re-reading
not just dune itself but probably you
know the the
the four books um
so i don't know we'll see what happens
this summer if it does happen it'll
happen this summer all right well we're
almost at the end of the hour people are
saying uh thanks uh take care stuff like
that so we can probably wrap this up
um i will see
all of you uh next week for well if
you're here for fernan von steinbergen
the young guy
and um
godot says maybe you can screen blade
runner for your students as part of the
course
yeah i'm going to give them links to the
the shows they can watch the shows on
their own right i don't i don't need to
screen it in class and take up valuable
class time with with that right uh
that that sort of supplementary stuff
class time is reserved for actually like
digging into things and discussion all
right i'll see all of you
i do have some stuff coming up this
weekend i should mention uh classic
metal class
again you can find it in the events
calendar and you can find it on on my my
facebook page and in my social media
scott truly and i are going to be
discussing the tiff between judas priest
and kk downing's priest
and going into some ethical issues with
that
and then there's the worlds of
speculative fiction coming up next
weekend as well so i'll see all of you
and have a great uh whatever it is for
you day night evening morning
whatever you happen to be
going through